[Music]
what's wrong with Papa's face bro what's
wrong with Papa's face bro did you
already eat shellfish I don't know did
he get stung by 47 bees that really does
look like he got he did so he's allergic
to something what's wrong Papa
so um I figured you acknowledge this at
all I don't know this looks weird maybe
skip that maybe it's a bad angle what do
you what are you gonna do oh no no
that's how it is
all right um this is a really quick one
Frozen is that every show Asian producer
so James Vic he would I guess you know
he was I think let go from UFC went to
karate combat so he lost his first fight
party combat but
you know Robin black
um boss ruten oh by the way this is the
Brandon shop show on thick boy networks
and I just skipped to the current event
segment section of his show GS I think
gsp2 yeah they're all part of combat
which is cool but I just thought this
looks cool
all this stuff MMA you have this strict
schedule what's going on
take a Benadryl he needs a Benadryl ASAP
something's happening he looks like he's
gonna explode no I mean we cover him a
lot so we see us what's going on with
his face
and that's not how he gained a little
weight that's not weight gain that's
like allergic puffiness yeah you all
right Bud Camp easy and locals said
ssris plus booze equals bloat okay
therapy
you're trying to achieve this goal and
then once that's over you wake up like I
don't have anybody I don't have a
schedule man and then depression comes
and it's it's dark and then you get a
Showtime special with your friends with
Joe Rogan and then nobody watches it and
then you do it again and it's even worse
it's shorter special that nobody cares
and then your friend fights Bobby Lee
for no reason and then you and then you
sue a [ __ ] drunk Mexican YouTuber and
then you uh then you then you then then
you say you're gonna bring the full
force to the U.S government on Bobby Lee
and then you you know you know and then
Joe Rogan says you need a Handler and
then you lie about him apologizing
normal stuff normal stuff yeah normal
dude [ __ ] yeah look hey who hasn't been
there merch who hasn't been there
yeah he said everyone deals with it he
said he got to a point where he was
looking at his firearm and thinking like
you know the he could potentially end
his life luckily he had people around
him to [ __ ] his dick hilarious yeah let
me refresh this real quick
is he even get into this I think Jake
doing the stuff karate I think he sent
into this in the same way that because
he's not into this because this is not
his little thick Boy network right and
his little thick Point network doesn't
get the same views as like when him with
him and Callan or him and anybody else
really so no probably not
you know it's like what do you do yeah
of course they're depressed but then the
numbers aren't going to go up if you're
not into it so why do it you're just
going to be stuck in this box because I
think honest my opinion I think he's
trying I think Papa's trying to prove
that he could do something on his own I
think Papa's trying to prove that he
could carry a show but if he's not he's
bouncing off his produce at all times he
produces no more talking than he has
exactly what I was about to say but have
you ever watch these shows it's either
him or big gay lion
bouncing back and forth with him which
is fine I mean I don't care but it's
like I really think that he's doing this
to prove to people like look Tomball B
I'm not as dumb as they say you know
but then he just sits here and he's not
even into it no mostly with athletes too
because they're Windows smaller than
hell yeah and soldiers think about that
yeah that too and soldiers
um all right so this is also interesting
well I'll just play this clip for you
this is Jake Paul telling Dana White to
suck his dick this would be like if we
did our show right and you just kept
throwing prep like rapidly out there and
I just kept snow selling all of it
you're like yeah man did you see the
polls this week did you see this clip in
the Sanders and that fits like if I just
was like yeah yeah
yeah man politics man hey Murph why is
your face so puffy are you all right bud
yeah man only one eyes open are you okay
man I'm fine it starts for fun [ __ ]
only I have
I just I had some shellfish
yeah okay did it have Rohypnol in it
yeah
assist letters
because
some clips of Anderson we're not a
[ __ ] and they're talking about this
so I'll play a little bit
somebody somebody had him Brennan in
this article is Conor McGregor he might
actually you know end up uh retiring is
it yeah
that's that's crazy
like all right are you gonna give me
anything man it's like okay I got all
the prep like all right we're gonna We
were supposed to have a conversation I
just feel like I'm talking about things
and you're going yeah
all right cool it's like does he know
the show started
he sounds like he's trying to hang up
the phone with a girl like yeah yeah
you have word word uh-huh yeah that's
that's the funniest description of it
I've ever heard all right that's crazy
all right
yep wow that's crazy I know that's nuts
I'm so sorry
congratulations or I'm sorry that
happened to you I'm not reading all that
urges MMA fans to boycott Jake Paul's
future fights and he's saying why are we
still pandering to this piece of that's
weird and I mean I can kind of get it
trust me I get it let's see
um well okay
have you ever seen him read
I've seen some like rarely but yeah I've
seen it happen all right
we should all boycott the rest of his
fight until you find someone who's on
his level whatever level we deem him to
be why are you
just because you're reading fast doesn't
mean people can't tell you can't read
but not only that he's like he's
forgetting that you're doing a show
so you're going to pull up a statement
you usually read the statement out loud
clearly for the audience you don't just
go uh let's see uh shouldn't be doing
fights with Jake Paul as you know what's
going on yeah
could you imagine our podcast listeners
hey you know what it's like it's again
it's like it's what it's talking to a
girl and they send you a text message
and you read the first sentence in the
last sentence so you get the idea but
you don't gotta read the whole thing and
just repeat back the last couple things
wow really that happened
but the other thing is like he reads he
reads it really really fast like he
flies through it so he's not even
understanding what he's saying and
somebody the one of the top comments on
this video is Brennan is the only person
who could interrupt himself
yes will be fought to the level that the
internet deems him to be Anthony who
would he fight
I'm sure
you know what I'm saying like do you
guys think he's the worst of all time so
who should if he predicate based off the
internet predicated
predicated based off the internet is not
a correct sentence that's not proper
English sentence that's that's silly you
talk all this [ __ ] about anime facts
about you see then you pretend that you
want to bring fires up okay no no no no
no no no no no listen you have like 43
podcasts you don't know how to read on a
show man
why are you trying to speed read
ER you can't normal read
well he's but he's doing the Mumble
speed read that idiots do when they say
words out loud because because he
probably reads like that off the air
he's probably like reading out loud like
you know because he's like but like he's
doing it for himself not his audience
I'm just the most obnoxious I'm just
proud they just have to put a finger
under the sentences to read them so
that's [ __ ] Improvement
I was going to the
fight today junior really you talk all
this [ __ ] about my first talks about you
see then you pretend that you want to
bring fires up and you want everyone to
get paid better but you trash ruin every
time they fight
um
but he's in trash Anderson yeah a lot of
respect yeah yeah now you notice you
notice this is a new Brendan that's not
going after Dana White now he's
defending Dana White it's almost like
maybe it wasn't an apology phone call
but it was like stop talking about Dana
you [ __ ] [ __ ] from Joe Rogan yeah
it's almost like maybe you do need a
Handler that's not a gay lion
foreign
Tigers running ruining their bodies into
[ __ ] car accidents but all these guys
near and do our hearts go [ __ ] yourself
like or even Panda speed [ __ ] yeah what
oh my God I'm sorry but what are you the
Micro Machines guy
so above no because he actually did
fasting and you could understand him
yeah you're right
it's it's I've you're the worst reader
I've ever heard
yeah I think after the the hate he
should stare towards other people
you realize the answer made more money
in this fight he's ever made would they
made more of a funny more money than
he's ever made what now you're not even
reading now you're just talking like
this hold on hold on so this isn't a
reading thing this isn't a reading thing
it's getting he's just getting worse
this isn't a reading thing this is a
this this is a thing can I can I say
what I think it is sure
well brain damage obviously well besides
that
I think he's also starting to
play it fast and lose a little with the
drinking and maybe some other stuff
is but Papa's depressed got it he's got
depression bloat you know and he's just
you know look at that place look at all
that booze I mean he's always got a ton
of booze in all his Studios uh I I think
he's in a um you know a funk yeah
been asking made more money he's ever
made not also he's not good then why is
he beating these guys and then he's also
advocating for fighter pay he's the only
one with this magnitude of a platform to
even get close to Bringing attention to
it so I would say he's doing a lot more
for don't you have the platform aren't
you a big [ __ ] guy why aren't you
bringing it
oh yeah he says you're just promoting
Jake Paul so Anthony Smith he's like
let's not promote him but you talked
about you know so that's promoting and
people aren't cheap they're gonna be
like I'm actually in tune in this maybe
if even if they even to see him get beat
up you're still who tunes into this to
get gems of wisdom from the stupidest
man on Earth
I I don't understand stupid or men
the ratio is always bad like it always
has more dislikes
I need to clean up comments
um well let me let me change it to
newest because that's the easiest way to
tell
yikes
okay cool he can box Brandon Brennan
Brennan took a half hour segment to make
himself believe Jake Paul's boxing a
stage we don't care
uh shop think about how stupid you sound
right now also Shaw people think Chris
Rock writes my jokes
did chop really say that people think
Chris Rock writes his jokes I need that
and I need that right now
because that to me is one of the most
insane statements I've ever heard
I think Chris Rock wrote his pico de
gallo bit
my wife always be talking about Pico the
guy how many people you like Mexican
food
you should hear Chris Rock's fajita but
it's fire got it
I got it Papa when you say that that's
that's a compliment [ __ ] you were
like such a millisecond quicker when you
say that that's that's a compliment
that's such a compliment
it's the same thing I've had people go
shop don't write his jokes there's no
way they come to the show yeah because I
mean they have to be written by a child
maybe like a baby some sort of mentally
[ __ ] baby is writing these I mean it
has to be someone who doesn't have like
a funny funny Center in their brain yeah
he just like bought one of those AI
writing programs and just put in a bunch
of Mexican foods mm-hmm
and then Martel yeah this guy you know
thinks she has someone writing jokes
like damn that's a compliment dude they
think that what do you think Chris Rock
trying them Chris Rock crying him
that's a compliment because you think
people are writing your jokes
yeah but to be fair I didn't actually
say Chris people specifically think
Chris Rock wrote and he's saying what do
you think Chris Rock's right now who's
random
I'm like oh man that's dope I'm never
like what that's ridiculous no dude hell
yeah man [ __ ] yeah you think someone
else never mind he did imply it yep
that's dope dude that's great
that means it's a good show it was so
good you think somebody else is writing
it hell yeah dude this is well so you're
saying is that people so even you're
trying to take this a compliment you're
implying that wow you're really stupid
you could say words somebody else has to
write that for you because you're so
dumb you just seem so dumb all the time
it's great this is fantastic so with
Jake same thing exact same thing
he's so Fame remember when he was said
he's basically like The Rock when he was
giving the rock advice
that was probably one of my all-time
favorite
things when he was saying yeah me and
The Rock we're the same Papa we're like
the same dude yeah they're both big
[ __ ] Moguls yeah no no I'm sorry
one's a mogul the other's a [ __ ] uh